Mike the situation Sorrentino was
sentenced to eight months in prison for
tax evasion the 36 year old reality star
appeared in federal court in Newark New
Jersey on Friday receiving major support
from his Jersey Shore co-stars Snooki
Vinny Deena
Pauly D JWoww and Ronnie were all
spotted outside the courthouse
along with sorentino's fiance at Lauren
according to a tweet from a journalist
who was on site Jersey Shore family
vacation cameras were around to capture
the cast wandering around the city as
Sorrentino entered court a day prior
Snooki was a guest on the Jenny McCarthy
podcast where she revealed how the cast
was feeling honestly we don't know
what's gonna happen tomorrow we're all
like freaking out for him so hopefully
you know everything's gonna be fine
we've been hanging out all week and you
could tell you know the days are coming
quicker and he says he's getting more
nervous and you know we're just trying
to be there for him and you know just
hang out with him make him smile a
little bit but it's terrifying for him I
think we just all want it to be over but
we're also hoping for a great outcome
Sorrentino and his brother Mark pleaded
guilty in January to tax evasion
both were initially indicted in
September 2014 for tax offenses with
additional charges added in April 2017
the reality star spoke with et in March
ahead of the Jersey Shore family
vacation premiere where he explained his
plans to try and move forward you have a
little bit of a tough road ahead of you
what's your headspace that right now
you want to have respect for the system
the judge and and things like that so
you know I did my best to better myself
become better and not bitter and I
continue to better myself I'm like how
can I you know continue to continue to
better myself I'm like you know what let
me help others so you know I'm trying my
best to take on challenges and continue
to move forward are you worried at all
about what's ahead are you at peace with
it I'm at peace with it yeah what are
people gonna be surprised to see from
you this season and what are you a
little bit anxious for people to see I
just want people to see the new
situation you know what I'm saying the
new and improved situation and you'll be
surprised but you say
[Music]
[Applause]